local health officials reminding
nevadans about the dangers of any
misinformation about covet christian
casares joining us live in studio with
more on a local campaign with the goal
to squash rumors well brian what if a
simple conversation could save a life
well that is a message from the southern
nevada health district as they roll out
a series of public service announcements
it's a covid conversation many psas at
the southern nevada health district is
launching to get accurate covet
information out to the community some
myths stating the covet 19 vaccines
aren't safe and developed too quickly
others doubting the source where the
information came from local health
officials reminding residents about the
common side effects of the vaccine on
your arm and the rest of your body a big
push to eliminate any rumors about the
vaccine to those who are possibly on the
fence about getting it the biggest thing
with patients is to understand first
what their fear is because people have a
lot of different concerns about this
some people will have a concern that
it's too new some people have a concern
that it's untested some people have a
concern that the government is planting
microchips in their body and some people
are just concerned because they don't
know and they're not sure what to be
concerned about dr dominic martinello
with southern hills hospital tells us
identifying the person's concern is the
first step could i be allergic or can
the vaccine make me sick he says these
are valid concerns which can be
addressed on a case by case but overall
the vaccine is nothing different than
others we get
officials also reminding parents about
vaccines for their children ages five
and older to schedule your vaccine or
even a booster shot visit 8 news now dot
com christian casa is live local now